la parole est à notre collègue patrick
chaize pour le groupe l'est républicain
je vais la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais la question s'adresse à
monsieur emmanuel macron la
généralisation du très haut débit sur
les territoires fait partie des
priorités partagées du gouvernement et
des collectivités le plan gouvernemental
france très haut débit pour tous a été
mise à jour au printemps dernier avec
une modification des critères de
subventions rentrant dans le cas des
aides d'état
ce cahier des charges a fait l'objet
d'une transmission pour avis à la
commission européenne
les collectivités sont aujourd'hui très
inquiète de la position récente de la
commission qui met en cause le
dispositif qui lui a été notifiée sans
doute et on peut le regretter un peu
tard le point bloquant et le dispositif
de montée en débit sur cuivre alors que
le passage à la fibre jusqu'à l'abonné
n'est pas remise en cause selon la
commission l'aide apportée pour être
illégale étant entendu que les
subventions publiques ont pour effet
d'améliorer le réseau cuivre propriété
de l'opérateur historique
il en résulte que le déblocage de fonds
du fsn ne sont pas effectuées alors que
de nombreuses collectivités ont déjà
réalisé les travaux à ceci viennent
s'ajouter la position de la dg fip qui
ne permet plus le remboursement de la
tva sur ces travaux renchérissant de 20%
leurs coûts puisque le dispositif de
récupération par le fonds de
compensation s'est arrêté au 31 décembre
aussi des collectivités principalement
rurale vont-elles devoir suspendre des
travaux pour des questions de trésorerie
et de budget voire de rembourser les
subventions perçues qualifié d' aides
d'état illégales
dans ces conditions on va envisager vous
un aménagement des règles relatives à la
montée en débit sur les réseaux filaires
et retient en concertation avec l'arcep
les opérateurs mais aussi les
collectivités proposerez-vous le retour
du fctva
plus globalement quand espérez-vous
l'accord de la commission sur le plan
france très haut débit et le déblocage
des fonds afin que les objectifs
affichés de vienne pour notre pays des
réalités pour un réel aménagement du
territoire pour vous répondre
la parole est aux mini
en charge des relations avec le
parlement vous avez la parole monsieur
le président merci mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nos cieux le sénateur je
pense qu'à travers votre question il est
important de noter que healy a
aujourd'hui dans notre pays une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
qui donne la priorité à l'installation
du haut débit c'est un engagement du
président de la république qui s'est
traduit par le plan france très haut
débit pour équiper tous les français
d'ici 2022 la mobilisation d'ailleurs de
tous les territoires est désormais
réelle
il réalise un réel travail aux côtés de
l'état pour démocratiser le numérique
monsieur le sénateur 89 départements se
sont dotés d'un plan de redéploiement
correspondant à 7 millions de foyers
équipés en fibre optique en zones
rurales ce sont des faits qui montrent
d'ailleurs plutôt que la polémique
l'intérêt de la mobilisation des
collectivités territoriales et de l'état
nous sommes interrogés d'ailleurs sur
l'effort qui a été fait par la
commission européenne vous avez que très
peu abordé cette question et c'est
pourtant un élément très importante que
d'obtenir l'accord des de l'union
européenne pour que nous puissions
continuer à aider le développement sur
nos territoires de la filière haut débit
voilà l'action du gouvernement monsieur
le sénateur est donc là encore je pense
que la polémique n'est pas de mise
il s'agit donc aujourd'hui non pas de
remettre en cause auprès de la
commission la pertinence mais il s'agit
effectivement de vérifier que nous le
faisons selon les critères qui sont
aujourd'hui reconnus voilà monsieur le
sénateur l'action qui est celui qui est
celle du gouvernement
bien sûr dans le débat budgétaire vous
pourrez faire un certain nombre de
propositions conclut jo l'imaginent
seront gagés sur les 150 milliards de
baisses d'impôts que votre formation des
nervis propose au front
et merci